1:18 to play Ingram hits the screen once
a ball for three got it there you go
now we have some tight basketball smart
basketball let's see the coaching in the
backcourt Beverley and Leonard he's
forcing you to match up here now
defensively
montrezl harrell will inbound and Hart
picking up Leonard's 94 feet s is smart
era winner sets the screen a switch hard
on to Williams 8 on the shot clock
Leonard trying to post up ball and gets
the ball Leonard on the block there it
is and he missed it but a Patrick
Beverley again with a key offensive
rebounds great rebound and a terrific
effort because he came to the other side
of delays
he is a triple effort of Patrick
Beverley and the nail from
Williams has it better right there a
professional score now this comes down
to now you use the timeout so now you
have one timeout left
pelicans up one timeout left and you're
down six the main thing is right now
you've got to get a ghost foot score do
not assume that they're gonna call a
timeout if you score make sure that you
are on them and now we'll come down your
strategy how how much time is left from
the frontcourt ball to in back try to
free up JJ reddick good contest by
Harrell phonetic trulson all right that
is 28 seconds here now they just need a
stop okay now the big thing is you got
to get a stop and remember skew the
pelicans have one timeout left so if you
get a stop and tough calls a timeout of
all the time and found against JJ Redick
get it insulators we're gonna get smart
four second difference between shot
clock and game clock down to five
I didn't say they wanted to switch to
ball and in fact they got the switch
they want step-back three on the way
strong time rebound timeout pelicans run
at the two point four to go
and now the gingers can argue for a
little bit more time on the they take
the ball and bounce okay here we go
ball to inbound Harrell contesting the
inbound pass Redick launches for three
and it ends with the Clippers winning
133 to